l'épisode de cette semaine et présenté
encore une fois par jus frais pour
investir jus frais comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est des jus frais dans le
fond les juges vous les commandez en
ligne sont préparés le soir même qu'ils
sont livré chez vous si vous êtes dans
le secteur de montréal sinon sinon le
temps que ça prend à les livrer fils le
propriétaire fondateur de chiffres est
venu me portais des jus à l'appart puis
croyez moi sont vraiment forts king
frais mais sont surtout fois king bon
c'est le match tu lèves tu veux prendre
un jus qui qui goûte pas trop chimique
qui god juste les phoques imf ruimin
riche de givray juba du cocktail du
packing jus pire les jus de jus frais
c'est précisément ce gros coup de coeur
je la vis de la dernière fois mais
encore une fois sur le jus de pomme t1
jp gaultier pomme
bah ouais c'est vraiment une grosse
différence entre un vrai jus de pommes
puis info j'ai comme tout le monde le
sait puis le café glacé aussi une cote
de promaude hommes c'est quoi les promos
de jus frais ouais dans le fond en un
code promo avec vous ne connaissez on ne
soit compromis pour vous csf 10,7 en
majuscules j'avais 10 % de ravir sur
votre commande de jus frais les frais de
livraison c'est trop de lancers dans six
secteurs de montréal vous avez vous jure
le lendemain de votre commande
puis cet extérieur c'est les frais de
postes canada de ben normal
la plateforme est 100 % à l'inpi une
nouvelle saveur aux petits fruits qui
est semble-t-il d'électeurs et délicieux
ont exposé en avoir demain sur le phoque
gens d'écouter cela avec mon déjeuner
avec mes crêpes mon petit des crevettes
ou le talent est grave il
les formats de 230 millilitres pardon à
un dollar vraiment pas cher vraiment bon
vraiment frais merci la gagne de chez
jus frais je suis pas avec compagnie
aller les encourager
pilati caire
le podcast est également présentée par
électronique une série kling associés
chaîne c'est une organisation à but non
lucrative qui reprend vos vieux
appareils électroniques qui les prend et
qui le soleil sexuelle et utilise en
fait tout lui redonne au suivant une
personne dans le besoin qui a besoin qui
fait du télétravail par exemple toit de
la maison un étudiant des gens dans le
besoin qui peuvent bénéficier d'articles
électroniques alors on a tout à la
maison dès fois quelque chose qui traîne
un appareil les connais concert puces et
laisser le temps de donner c'est
important puis ça peut vraiment faire
plaisir à quelqu'un cette compagnie-là
prendre votre appareil et s'assurer que
si elle est donnée là dessus qu'ils vont
être détruites fait que moi je sais que
je voudrais pas que personne accès à mon
laptop ou un téléphone ça pourrait être
gênant mais ils vont détruire ces
données l'oeil et jamais personne qui
vont voir quoi que ce soit de personnel
sur vos appareils
en fait en ce moment avec leur
confinement qui semble s'éterniser puis
va durer encore on l'imaginent pour un
certain temps on peut pour voir les gens
retournent à l'école encore ou retourner
au travail
donc c'est d'autant plus important
maintenant de redonner aux suivants
parce qu'en ce moment il ya des gens qui
sont chez eux qui ont pas aucun moyen de
travailler ou qui ont un équipement
vraiment médiocre pour faire ce qu'ils
ont à faire alors que peut-être que vous
vous êtes chez vous assis sur mon vieux
laptop qui sert plus à rien puis vous
avez juste vous savez juste pas quoi
faire avec electronic recycling
association veut aller voir au 1er à
point ca pour avoir plus d'informations
sur pour planifier des cueillettes où
vous pouvez appeler le numéro ici au 1 8
7 7 9 3 9 2 7 8 3
donc honnêtement de nos suivant et
surtout ne jetez pas vos appareils
électroniques sous prétexte que vous
voulez
nouvelle affaire allez vous acheter des
nouvelles affaires et donné l'ancien
affaires au suivant à des gens qui en
ont besoin
fait qui remercie pour le support du
podcast ra sans qui tout se serait pas
possible
yes moscou une production du studio sf
bio venus sans fil dans le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos invités
date site iam ph quentin 8 me tue des
isde plats sont détruits georges saga
saw a dit oui oui oui le civc semaine
des filtres vigiles fortin qui est juste
à ma femme de m haies mais on la barre
georges st pierre mais si c'est bon car
oui oui c'est vrai virginie est qui une
humoriste que vous connaissez qui une
comédienne également et qui est une
philosophie vraiment c'est probablement
le podcast propose de plus des questions
existentielles ou est ce que on
questionne le plus laid genre de chose
qu'on prend pour acquis que qu'on va
questionner enfermé camané ondimba à la
visite même virginie a continué de
questionner et de remettre en question
ces choses là qu'on prend pour acquis
ces systèmes l'argent tout sous le
capitalisme on est vraiment rapidement
tomber parce qu'on voulait refaire le
monde ou est ce qu'on voulait
tout change et épi tout ce qui
fonctionne pas déclamant les injustices
et ce très rapidement cet espoir
intéressant de se parler du bourg de sa
carrière comme en qui elle voit voit la
vie sa carrière si je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui aime profiter la vie pour
juste travailler travailler travailler
puis puis on profitera cannes aura 65
ans je pense que c'est des belles
valeurs
c'est très louable je pense que je pense
qu'on devrait essayer d'appliquer un
petit plus
c'était vraiment si on la connaissait
pour les deux ont un terrible que la
majorité des invités puis je prendrai
rapidement on y tombe et onu d'iphones à
nous parler de peine à faire entre lady
g en parle encore ouais dans un autre
ordre d'idées on est en train de
finaliser l'inscription notre nouveau
parti politique donc aux prochaines
élections provinciales vous allez
pouvoir voter pour qu'on devienne le
premier ministre du québec
j'allais dire du land ce serait aux
élections planète heures la prochaine
fois blague
braga por vous pouvez vous abonner à
notre pétillante moi ce qu'on discute
avec un après chaque podcasts ont fait
encore moins de filtres sélectifs ou
est-ce qu'on discute avec un dsk qu'on
discute avec un des vins qu'abonné vous
la tue on déconne ni qui nous rejoint et
nicole pardon pour les non initiés il
nous rejoint pendant là encore moins de
filtres parce qu'on discute avec lui du
podcast convient d'avoir donc
abonnez-vous là-dessus ce nom partager
la bonne nouvelle par les envois mipi
bonne écoute
bon pas de carte avec virginie avec un
vix
[Musique]
lesquels ouais puis sous écoute je pense
que d'écouter une coupe de france -
marchés
non j'en rêve c'est mardi contre métier
entre merci d'être ça roule ça tourne
tu disais on parlait justement juste
avant qu'on commence à tourner commenté
active dans les temps chauds pelez les
médias québécois depuis le début la
cabine depuis le début la deuxième vague
du genre je te laisse lens ont joué
andrée oui je comprends pas en fait
c'est vrai je comprends juste pousser
quoi les règlements de cette deuxième
vague parce que moi
au moins de mars par si j'étais comme
j'ai reçu je désinfecte mon épicerie je
vais commander le genre j'ai pris le
métro pour venir cité puis je veux
travailler je travaille je croise du
monde tout le monde son masque on est
ici en ce moment mais j'imagine que
c'est plus souple à gaz puisque le monde
prenne des mesures aussi mais le montant
des mesures mais je ne sais plus opaque
aux faux faux faux que le cachalot faut
pas que le cas charrette de rouler là
c'est vraiment mais c'est plus se tait
d'un côté ces gens respecté les
consignes
il faut être en même temps que baisse
des coûts pour l'économie de la chose
j'ai l'impression c'est vraiment juste
pour que le système continue de rouler
alors qu'on on aurait pu profiter de ce
grand malheur pour tout détruire samassa
remet le titre a commandé des humains on
s'entraide on s'aime qui l'argent dans
le fond on l'inventé factor on annule
trucs pour l'instant l'argentin concept
existe
on a décidé le flamand fait des pieds et
des mains pour continuer de vivre comme
la gagne on arrête on arrête on arrête
tout pis quand un vaccin mais on est
juste à revenir a aussi qui étaient les
chiffres quoi ce qu'on dit mais
peut-être pas mais qu'un mode comment
qu'on peut fonctionner au drame
voici cinq questions jusqu en clamant sa
marche pour quelque chose qui kiffent
octobre mais mettons ces images d'un
monde qui fonctionne autrement
mais si on le savait peut-être que non
je pense pas ça s'est fait parce que
parce qu'il ya des gens qui en fait
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui en profitent
de ce système
moi je pense que ce que ça prend c'est
un salaire maximum mais en même temps
j'ai aucun géo et j'ai aucune étude de
l'humain à l'intérieur de moi cette vie
c'est pas le salaire minimum pour
augmenter ses salaires maximums qu'il
faut implanter
ça sert à rien salaire minimum si les
choses qui coûtent de plus en plus chers
c'est parce que j'ai l'impression que
moi c'est un concept qui joue mais
l'idée de salaires demeurent encore dans
tout dans dans le système dans lequel on
est le tuer oui c'est sûr qu'il dit
ouais mais bon un rapport ce podcast le
un salut la gac breton il faut le tuer
en accord avec ça
il pleut il pleut mais là plus qu'un
concept la plus une semaine c'est quoi
le terme une simulation vous mettez la
faire avec l'argent c'est que c'est que
c'est complètement inégal sa répartition
moi je peux me sentirais mal en ce
moment d'être milliardaire la maison je
me suis donc être la solution à
pratiquement tous les problèmes dans le
système tant dans une banque ans juste
après ça ce que je pense c'est pour
pouvoir continuer à vivre avec l'argent
mais que les gens en profitent tous un
petit peu plus faudrait que tout soit en
co op
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas une personne
au top d'aucune entreprise qui finit
avec + d'attin amené qantas et
d'argenton argent fait de l'argent tout
seul si je comprends pas non plus a
fallu ce qu'elle veut mais elle expliqué
mais je comprends pas que l'argent
puisse faire de l'argent ce jeu aura pas
qu'on puisse décider de sortir de
l'argent du roulement pour qu'ils
continuent à faire de l'argent ce qui
fructifie have been puis ça en fait
s'enrichir sur les prêts que les banques
font à des gens qui en ont besoin qu'ils
ont besoin une pré cb de l'intérêt c'est
toi qui vas tâche l'intérêt au bout de
ce facteur
en tout cas je sais pas si c'est
possible de changer vu qu'on est tous
des humains puis les humains où on sait
tous amenés jusqu'à sept points huit ans
mettons là un concept qui serait que moi
je réfléchis je me dise ça sonne comme
une bonne idée
c'est tu étudies l'être humain décide
d'établir à quel moment est ce que le
niveau de vie art est d'augmenter fermer
ton mettons que dit la 125 millions par
année ton niveau de vie que non mais non
mais non non mais c'est un énorme sauf
que c'est sûr que met-on c'est sûr qu'il
ya une énorme différence dans ton niveau
devienne quelqu'un qui fait 15 millions
quelqu'un qui en fait 75
c'est la différence est en est quand
même un motivateur pour vouloir te
rendre le fait que tu fais des études
doigt ce qu'était établi qu'un est ce
que le niveau de vie art est d'augmenter
quand tu peux plus le plus augmenté tout
est arrivé très pur
montée de die hard tu peut plus
augmenter son niveau de vie à partir de
là prend tout le reste qui redistribue
le puits tout cet argent là qui
contribuent pas à augmenter son niveau
de vie au final on sent comme chez moi
je vois même pas pourquoi qu'on avait le
droit de se rendre à cette ope de niveau
de ville alors ça nuit à peu près à tout
apprécié au tgcc le fait de d'avoir la
possibilité d'avoir un fini à faire des
jetty comme le monde le commun des
mortels travail dans sa petite job à
faire un salaire minimum pour finalement
subvenir aux besoins inventé de la
personne qui a un jet privé une île pitt
est en fait ça c'est ce qu'on fait si
peu et on continue qui ont respiré dans
cette affaire le parce que tout le monde
cultive les sports que ça pourrait être
de personnes nous tenons quand le
français fait que c'est ce qui nous
gardent leur espèce de ce que moi je
sais pas comment cordes et invente tout
ce qu'on y vend 10 mai mais au fond
moody's met 10 millions de dollars 10
millions de dollars j'avais fait un
numéro à juste pour rire une couple
d'années où ce que je dis mais je pense
que personne ne veut voir le droit de
posséder plus que 10 atteindre 20
millions à l'époque je tiens vraiment
j'avais le capital mais type mais je
comprends le principe métier moi mettons
15 225 millions ccg même équivalentes
on va prendre un chemin mais qu'on fait
oui il va toujours avoir résisté aux
coups qui ont le goût d'avoir aidé ça
n'est pas si bête on côté milliards da
si moralement qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
ça parce qu'avec son flanc top qui
attend un million de la base a meta qui
serait le fun c'est qu'ils aillent pas
être une entrave voyons que c'est un
individu qui juge cette décision le pays
va t on et comment ouais mais il est
assez fin il donne de son argent
j'espère une personne qui prend cette
décision là il
y en a dix qui apprennent paul sackey
s'est privatisé le socialisme bravo le
pouvoir dominant les divisions avons
décidé sur qui personne n'a voté et on
s'entend là-dessus qu'ils achètent pas
les podcasts jeu la musique le pillage
avaient dérapé depuis qu'on jette c'est
plus long et tout genre t on parlait
justement des tout petits prix le pc une
à nantes les gens ou à ma team je me
sens mal parce que si ces hôpitaux
pilosité je voulais pas dépasser nolan a
jeté comme entraîneur des petits dés on
fait tout ce titre à 1000 par année puis
gens rencontrent nos scènes qui ont sans
mal genre d'aidé profiter du système de
demandes font des millions qui trouve le
maillet pays 02 l'ordre exact c'est nous
autres le problème
six heures c'est tout temps les gens qui
en ont moins qui sont le plus conscient
de l'importance du dub ce coup de gueule
pense que ça serait correct qu'on cross
nous autres le système le catch fait 52
pièces par année
c'est très correct on creuse un petit
peu le système non mais c'est comme
quand quelqu'un dit pas à l'épicerie
pièce à photos que tu es comme ayo volet
de volée mais s'était rendu à vannes une
niche le sais que tu as besoin de suivre
alors qu'est le monde qui ont de
l'argent ils veulent l'argent le thé les
banquiers goudé fois le labour le
principe de banque lui ça me dépasse
comme ça paraît vous en prenez notre
cash leur check in motion
ça y est vous êtes caché le bug le monde
travaille proche de l'argent c'est le
monde qui ont l'air d'en avoir le plus
pur des come away lui je voyais faire
confiance avec mon cas je voyais aux
touristes des glaces desjardins énorme
et tout comme promène dans le parking
puis anthony charteau mais déjà way
desjardins six ans on voit non mais il
apparaît que c'est vrai mon cap je
regarde d'une rolex
ok je te fais confiance avec mon cas je
voudrais je ferais confiance avec mon
cash à la personne qui se perd comme un
pick up qui prend le transport en commun
si j'oserais ma botte 6% genre est une
bonne ville où la personne qui est com -
pour que tu puisse accéder at on cache
dans votre forum pays via ce même si
c'est mon cas je me dis pouvait le
maître mot du comité de la banque qui
change
je voyais que mon ami karim d'oddo qui
libanais tes pieds en pharmacie le pays
l'économie va super marrant le monde ont
placé leur argent dans une banque
ils y ont mis le pilot ils l'ont perdu
mais oui de rennes reste le pot je t'ai
donné mon argent mais je peux pas le
rappeur non le pue le café les autres on
les sauve les banques à chaque fois
qu'ils avaient fait ça il serait en
prison
c'est ce que j'arrêtais belle robe de
mettre littéralement mon cash en
coupures dans bebo dans le congélateur
de leur encore exact sauf que ton cash
papier tu peux de plus ou de moins en
moins t'en servir ces hippies même avant
la pandémie c'est ça il ya des places
le rappel d'une époque où on pouvait
juste payé cash la carte est comme ça va
tenir un point de vente et la
maintenance et comme au départ j'ai donc
plus tchatche peu juste payer la carte
fac dans le fond pour exister il faut
que tu sois absolument fillier en banque
ou c'est juste pour vivre mais je pense
au rouge ou gens justement qui
il l'itinérance l'appui qui ramasse une
coupe 200 qui veulent aller au foot
courtes sans titine s'acheter qu'elle
est si tu prends juste la carte
pardon c'est je suis ridicule on ne
gomme pas le choix d'exister
financièrement et qu'une bande pour
exister puis on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
une carte qui est des basques prennent
juste la carte de crédit peut pas jouer
deux matchs et demi sur lequel tu sois
fait les intérêts étaient obligés d'être
détectée est obligé d'emprunter de
l'argent
on va simplement pour payer attentats
facture si les gens sont un peu comme
moi non mais parce que ça me fait
capoter les gens me disent on est des
humains on aurait pu toute façon ce
temps et on va se bâtir quelque chose de
l'fun la garde saint comme appât du gain
mais non finalement il fallait
absolument qu'on a et qu'on augmente de
quoi parce que l'ours abris bus de
podcasts les plus choqués quand après ça
comment met on met donc dit et l'idée
utopique de drag et est maintenant faite
et des raisons que le communiste pas
marché je pense que le capitalisme
marche toi ben c'est sûr que ça marche
mieux ça marche mieux c'est sûr que ça
marche mieux oui parce que mettons
comment comment excuse si les sites
t'enlève l'idée d'un salaire de médecin
il me demande comment tu formes des
médecins qu'est ce qui justifie que
quelqu'un passe sept ans à l'université
minimum en faisant des 60 heures par
semaine à être tout le temps dans ce
livre à avoir pas de vie sociale
si au bout de ça il n'y a pas un gain
qui est matériel puis devrait avec le
risque que la job bossi tm est simple la
chinoise c'est sûr qu est-ce qui est pas
qu il faille à ce point les hiérarchiser
l'utilité d'une personne ne sait pas
l'utiliser d'une personne sauf que pour
que ces personnes ne soit utile il ya
tout le chemin qui doivent accomplir
pour se rendre à cette utilité le sait
mais ton c'est beaucoup plus facile
de faire un travail qui nécessite pas de
passer tout ce temps là sur des bancs
d'école à travailler comme un débile
c'est beaucoup plus facile face parce
que si on a pas d'école de formation on
n'a pas de médecin compétences
ça c'est dit quand même si jean je pense
que le sociologue et viser bas c'est à
cause de mon avis reçus mais
l'enseignement tel qu'il est et l'école
tels que c'est en ce moment ça sert
vraiment j'ai sa forme et les
travailleurs qui vont exister puis
travailler faire rouler le système tel
qu'il y faculty après ce jeu n'est pas
étudiant en médecine mais j'ai
l'impression que j'ai l'impression que
des médecins pourraient former d'autres
médecins qui pourraient former d'autres
médecins que pour informer d'autres
médecins puis l'enseignement au lieu
qu'ils soient l'enseignement au lieu
qu'ils soient comme une espèce à faire
imposer ça devrait être une affaire qui
soit juste comme valoriser je suppose
que c'est clair c'est toi qui on
formerait des médecins qui est ma france
aucun sens après un système qui dit ça
pour comprendre pourquoi ça prend un
gros du plan reva confiance à quelqu'un
qui m'ouvre le cerveau c'est d'hygiène
me faire enseigner par quelqu'un qu'il
faisait aucune instance de légitimité
que dit que cette personne là est
qualifié pour fonctionner l'instance de
limites c'est à vienne d'où tu lui fais
confiance à cause des établissements
scolaires qui ont réformé ces personnes
là je fais plus confiance que s'il y
avait dit j'ai appris sur le double oui
mais c'est sûr que d inventer tout le
système scolaire et de s'imaginer une
autre façon de passer la connaissance
puis le savoir sans que ça soit comme
organisée de façon à ce que on crée des
gens qui puissent rentrer dans un
système qui en sortent par obéissant de
ce système le multi c'est difficile de
ceux de se l'imaginer mais je pense que
ça va
si je comprends pas je comprends que
c'est complexe devenir médecin puis a
étudié sept ans mais la farce et qui en
existe des gens dépôts qui sait la
passion pis si au lieu au lieu au final
c'est souvent la passion de tout ces
gens là
celui-ci s'est enfin dit moi je veux pas
être opérée par un médecin qui est
devenue médecin parce qu'il voulait
faire 300 mails par année mais je veux
être opérée par un médecin ce que ça
change quelque chose si
qualifiés mais si c'est pas sa passion
c'est peut-être ce qui est qualifié
d'accord mais je trouve que encore une
fois la punt gains on dirait que ça flux
l'outil un petit rusal up pour sauver
les villes mais si je vois un médecin
qui est là pour les bonnes raisons mais
s'y est pas compétente mais il est là
pour les bonnes raisons c'est pas mieux
bt en même temps le système tel qu'il y
en a créé des médecins compétents
tout à fait c'est juste que je pense que
ça port de plus loin que il faut
simplement plus valoriser le savoir que
l'avoir tuée dans la ville puis je pense
qu'à ce moment là ça serait peut-être
mais après ça je trouve pas ça y est
juste manqué qu'un petit 17 ans puis
qu'ils fassent pas autant plus d'argent
que la personne qui travaille à shop de
soudure je trouve plus aussi injuste que
ça moi je vois pas en quoi c'est un
problème mais ça dépend de plusieurs
choses dans ce l une des premières
choses c'est la personne qui à gauche au
dessus du joueur à saint trop riche et
heureux
il profite de l'argent qui a fait il
profite de sa vie profite du reste la
personne qui est médecin à 5 heures ils
gardent peut parler nulle part avec ses
enfants un peu pas voir ses enfants
grandir la plupart du temps doit
toujours être réactif pour aller en
urgence à l'hôpital
je trouve pas que c'est des choses qui
sont équivalentes puis je trouve qu'il
faut qu'il y en ait un qui soit plus
qu'ils soient capables d'être d'être
plus mon expression qu'on assez
rémunérés parce que système qu'on essaie
sinon c'est quoi si si c'est pas la
valorisation de la société parce qu'on
s'entend qu'il revienne plus vite ils
n'y a aucun des deux qui plus valorisé
qui devrait être plus valorisé parce
qu'on a autant besoin de plombier que le
médecin fait que je suis d'accord qu'
aucun des deux qui prêtaient plus
valorisé maintenant comment est ce que
tu sais pas si ces deux affaires le ca
peut pas juste avec la passion puis il y
aussi la fac et noir que les risques
coûte plus cher est morte à soudure ses
idoles matimov chirurgie
siphat ah ouais effectivement mais le
met mais c'est pas l'argent c'est quoi
c'est pas l'argent qui non mais c'est ça
mais c'est dommage que comme que tout le
temps passé en famille vêtements que
tout ça soit compensée par l'argent cg
pas la solution mais je trouve ça triste
que ça
c'est sûr c'est pas la même chose
effectivement je dois cas que toi tu y
mets ton je pense que je change un peu
de sujet méticuleux la compétition que
le capitalisme apporte peut être bon
team est ok justement ton qu'on veut
développer un nouvel outil qui va faire
que mettons des enfants que la paralysie
cérébrale peuvent marcher mais que
quatre entreprises privées qui se
compétitionne pour trouver la machine
ultime aux autres le ciment ils savent
que s'ils réussissent ils vont faire de
l'argent mais n'empêche que le but de ce
puits vu qu'ils sont quatre expos
mettons un monopole ou se promenant le
gouvernement ils vont peut-être blue ap
le style comment tu l'argent sur le dos
des enfants qui est parce qu'au final
c'est super le dr monrose fil idées -
qui ont marché
oui je sais mais après ça encore une
fois j'ai pas la solution mais je trouve
ça dommage qu'on soit pas capable de
penser ça l'extérieur du capitalisme
parce que justement la confidence
parce que le but ce serait juste de se
mettre tous en forme pour trouver la
meilleure façon de souvenirs à ses
enfants l'homme et l'humain est ainsi
fait qu'il ait besoin d'être en
compétition n'en avoir d'avoir une
espèce de cadeaux afin qu'ils disent
m'irriter jugeant que le problème doit
être dans l'humain
moi j'ai l'impression j'ai ouï mais on
dirait que je veux c'est difficile de
déconstruire les affaires qui nous ont
été apprises et qui nous ont été
transmises
qu'est ce que c'est vraiment dans
l'humain ou est-ce que c'est dans la
façon dont on élève les humains en
société il était sûrement j mais c'est
sûrement tous en même temps
moi je suis parti six mois et mettons
l'espèce qui domine et on est rendus
loin on est l'espèce qui domaine la
planète piqué ticket que j'ai vraiment
pris contre
un petit peu quelque chose dans notre
nature qui fait qu'on est impitoyable et
puis qu'on pique on en veut deux minutes
qui a fait qu'on a pris vite le prix
libre les éléphants mais c'est quand à
nous au tout ce qu'ils ont fondée molly
tout n'est pas que c'est bon non quelque
chose que si on laisse passer quelque
chose quand même nature faudra me mets
moi j'ose imaginer qu'on est juste la
réalité alternative sur laquelle la
variable changeantes c'était l'argent
plus tu es comme le pic est sur une
autre planète terre dans une autre école
alternative mettons un peu comme les
cimes du riz le buste est l'âme au but
puis nous on est juste ce que la playa
de l'argent qui le montrent en train de
regarder le test comme ayant vraiment
merdé sont entrés tout depuis longtemps
simulation
jean step à la police et au moins la
virginie dans l'autre et altère les
simulations mais si au moins une réalité
alternative dans laquelle ils savent au
moins je n'ai pas de nom mais pas vrai
car quand on va trop dit bhl dans des
affaires de même vichy qu'elle a ma
gueule c'est quoi pourquoi qu'on est
pourquoi condé que je dise roumieu puis
je retourne dans l'espace puis médias il
ya eu on est juste deux ans j'adore
bizarre j'adore comment kate ou sur
série avec genre le titre de ton
spectacle
l'étude de mon spectacle ça m'habite de
choses qui m'habite les plus l'espace
arabe et de pichichi de fac c'est sûr
que toutes mes conversations chine
espère qu'ils parlaient que est ce que
est ce que depuis qu'il est tout petit
tu as l'impression combine le jeu vous
dire deux fois mon tout petit mais qu'on
est minuscule dans la halle elle la
grandeur des choses et c'est fait c'est
une dictée qui qui qui étaient là quand
tu étais petit c'était pas le fait
d'être minuscule quand j'étais petit
c'est vraiment le pot comprend 2
pourquoi qu'on existe maintenant c'est
quand depuis j'ai 4 5 1 le pipe ancien
beaucoup d'enfants qui pensent parfaite
être la question existentielle pourquoi
est-ce qu'on du bon quoi on existe moi
j'ai ma première hd j'avais demandé à
mon pauvre père qui essayait juste de me
dire bonne nuit jeté corps pourquoi si
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est bien pourquoi
c'est pas juste tout noirci mais
j'imaginais que l'absence d'existence
paix juste on est encore là mais dans
rien c'est tout neuf qui complètement
agoa fin puis après ce oui mais après ça
jamais été tant que ce on est donc un
tout petit mais plutôt de questions
pourquoi
qui sait ouais voilà que j'associe réel
ce qui se passe à un moment le nom
existe une importance quelconque amende
existence une importance à ton existence
mais dans le vide dans l'infini madame
ce que moi j'aime pas ça non mais
c'est des questions qui des fois pour
sédition
c'est tout simple c'est c'est sacré le
vertige de la pensée à ceux west bay
mois sacré et le vertige jusqu'à ce que
ça crie le pur réconfort le
éventuellement nous de faire comme dans
ce cas là pourquoi je stresse et sur
quoi juste réussi deux bottés ultime en
moi je suis confortable et georges et je
n'ai pas un mal de vivre je n'ai pas mal
nulle part donc mon existence pour
l'instant n'est peut-être n'est qu'un
jeu juste un peu le fun je sais pas si
ça en vaut je suis je sais pas quand
elle s'affine ici j'ai l'impression que
j'ai des choses que je veux le faire
puisque je veux devenir mais tout cela
se passe sur une petit parfum
d'explosion sur laquelle par pure
coïncidence et développer la vie sourit
le jeune justin lui niveaux créés par
une explosion et xen mettant le fait un
show ça ça se passe mal 30 si vous tapez
d'armes et a dit au moins il ya quelque
chose plutôt que rien
puis il existe donc ça 6 janvier chez
nous le sac avait été chez que c'est pas
au moins j'existais genre au moins je
m'habille tout ce que j'ai fait
disparaître mais ça aussi la force et
quelques autres collèges envier au
capitalisme mais on accumule des
affaires mais quand on meurt
y'a plus rien à payer actuellement mon
pas mais il mais carré parents sont
séparés puis fallait vider la maison
tiens il était super attachée à plein de
matériel à mes yeux de ses amis qui dit
une phrase à gaz que ça a changé sa vie
parce qu'ils me le répétait souvent
après ça c'est dit enfin faut que ça
rentre dans une petite boîte comme ta
vie le matériel qu'ils accumulent à
fresnes tout seul ça rentre dans une
petite boîte safina même place que tout
est 6e une fois que tout ça en pâte
dietsch quoi tu le sais vrai mais nous
les pauvres est juste et pas non plus
c'est quoi l'attrait de vouloir des
choses puymoyen genre j'en suis victime
le défi
en tout cas juge j'aime ça j'ai un
problème mais j'aime ça je t'ai déjà
fait c'est quoi mon problème que
poserait pas besoin pourquoi on veut des
choses quand quelque chose qui existe
est un humain et si quelqu'un qui ont
rien on t'a rien dans le fond le temps
mis pour montrer qu'il y avait quelque
chose que tu es quelqu'un et c'est ça
qu'on veut des choses mais ce genre
pourquoi qui a autant d'importance
accordée aux choses parce qu'il faut
acheter des choses pour faire rouler
l'économie sinon il ya toujours des vues
la discussion ouais il ya quelque chose
qui te dit tantôt la dichotomie entre le
sentiment de vertige quand tu penses à
l'univers peut aussi le sentiment bien
entre deux 48 pense puis ça me fait
penser à quelque chose qui est
activement j'essaie d'améliorer dans mon
quotidien c'est de remettre en
perspective toutes les choses qui avec
cette vision là la vision de drive temps
là on est vraiment minuscule ça permet
de remettre en perspective crissement
des enfants qu'un cas méthode en date
est quelque chose de négatif qui s'est
passé petit le tout le retourne thürler
tourner tout leur tombe pas le temps de
te dire
en rétrospective c'est sérieux c'est là
c'est le sentiment que j'ai en ce moment
de malaise ou d'anxiété si ça existe
pour savoir ça va descendre ça n'existe
plus mais le pire des cas et si moi
c'est mon outil aussi de faire quand on
est juste dans l'espace on s'en fout on
est même possible ça existe pour de vrai
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de vivre la
confirmation que j que j'ai studio c'est
que je suis dans moi j'ai fait dix fois
mettant quelque chose puis je retourne
chez nous qui jouons my god j'aurais
jamais dû s'appeler le jeu peu capables
de c'est pas si facile à dire mais c'est
pas facile à faire des vagues
mais on s'en fout on fera dans
l'infiniti wii sont encore de quand même
la vague impression d'exister plus
d'inclure pour nettoyer dans notre petit
corps guinée bolide pour nous déplacer
puis on est pogné avec nous autres qui
pensent dans notre tête l'accusent ses
six fils jésus oui c'est réconfortant
dis moi j'ai tout le temps comme on s'en
fout c'est juste la vie on flotte dans
l'infini mais j'peux pas capable de
l'appliquer
chaque situation de ma ville j'en passe
des affaires que j'ai fait jusqu'à
omagad et chaud dans sa chambre on est
dans un système dans des balises le tpiy
depuis décidé du transfert d mais faut
quand même de ton vivant vivre les
conséquences c'est d'avoir transcender
ses valises le salut bonjour puis dire à
jean ou qu'ils quittent l'impôt à m
c'est fait
oui à ce point comme pour vrai je vais
de ce pas parce qu'on fait dans les
faits dit que tout ce n'est qu'une jo
club
c'est absurde au journal sauf que en
fait ça dans l'absolu oui oui on dirait
qu'on n'est pas au choix de jouer un peu
si tu peux sortir des paramètres dans ta
tête tu te dirai comment on s'en fout
c'est dans les sillons flotte dans les
filles ça existe pas mais au final ça y
est on est quand même dans une réalité
avec ses seuls dans cette système loupé
cette société où est ce qu'ils font ce
travail puisse pas l'argent pour tout
devienne quelqu'un fait que tu peux pas
dire à gino chouinard tupi parti c'est
commun qui s'appelait le corps médical
oui oui cemex la volt en oeuvre d'art
c'est toi qui joues un nihiliste ou est
ce qu'il n'ya rien qui parce que tu es
tout cela parce que tu plantes dans les
messieurs c'est le rêve près cette
liberté a quand même raté ça m'arrivait
ou au secondaire ne nous a pour quelques
projets semelle vite bout d'un transfert
gamme
enfin je vais faire ça arrive les
conséquences seraient même possible
libre et finalement c'est comme la vie
est criant bio toi à tes réunion design
votre part les gros émoi crise parce que
je verbalise le jeu les jeux les
véhicules outre une fois y'a rien en ce
moment comme physiquement il n'y a rien
qui m'empêche de me lever puis farce
l'idée pas mais c'est pour ça qu'à moi
des fois je me dis j'en parlais de seul
dans le métro laisser des fois je voyais
du monde se parlait de selon le métro
puis au début j'ai déjà ok je vais les
écouter voir ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils
disent parce que tout à coup que c'était
dans ma phase dans ma phase je pense que
nous sommes tous dans un grand jeu qui
nous sommes tous conçus pour ne pas se
rendre compte qu'on est dans un grand
jeu je n'ai mais non mais pas autant que
pas autour de moi le tout autour d'une
double dit ce n'est pas à propos de moi
sinon que genre on est tourné en dix
conditionné acompte à continuer à vivre
dans ce grand jeu le s'en remettent en
question le jury sophie et des gens il
ya des petits pillon qui sont brisées
puis que d'autres y ont accès à ckoi le
juch si ces gens à l'aise parle seul
dans le métro s'est fait que je me suis
permis à les écouter voir si elles pas
des noms mais après bien précieux mais
c'est tout le monde moi je pourrais être
moi je pourrais citer père satan et
moutons gouvernement
mettez ça pourrait être moussaoui du
double dans le métro mais ça serait
juste à des fins ça serait juste pour
nous c'est vraiment juste le fait
d'avoir ces réflexions le questionner
sur textures un peu du jeu pareil si
fait pour que je me rende pas au bout de
mes qualités au niveau à chaque faute
sont loin de jeu mais
ce que je veux dire kiki qui jouent le
jeu sans même s'apercevoir qu'un jeu le
type qui aime avoir un haut niveau de
jeu le voit c'est ce we joue la game bon
moi je vois que gainey mais je ne sais
pas je pense que tout le monde un genre
de vertige existentiel qui à un moment
donné de sa vie puis qui décide ou non
de d'emprunter ce chemin là où poterie
immense
je pense que je pense que même la
personne que tu t'imagines qui avait
passé ses réflexions profondes le à
lézat mais c'est pas son mécanisme elle
s'est pas nécessairement de les partager
la vigilance si de fac
aujourd'hui j'arrête moi j'ai appelé ça
le jeu mais est sûr maintenant qu'ils
sont comme moi je pense qu'on est dans
un choix je pense ouais je pense que
tout le monde les a c'est juste que ça
fait c'est vrai que c'est vertigineux
[ __ ] aussi tant et aussi longtemps que
tu vois pas le plus profond plus dans
ces questions là tu vas en avoir peur
jusqu'à ce que tu apprécies moi j'ai pas
fait le tour sauf que le petit truc que
j'ai fait me ramène je sais pas pourquoi
j'existe
gilles je n'aurais jamais la réponse
c'est ce qui me réconforte dans mon
existence qu'elle n'est pas vraiment de
sens dans le fond c'est ça c'est le tour
de la question est-ce que je suis rendu
en ce moment mais ce poteau manquait pas
d'accepter le fait qu'on aura jamais de
réponse et quelque chose
non c'est sûr et il accepte ça très
conforte mais beaucoup de jeunes sans
angoisse a vanté pourquoi qu'on écrit
des religions pour que tous ceux
stakhovsky et santiago se trouve à
savoir bah oui c'est selon se trouvent
des réponses mais en même temps que ses
seules à la philo la philo est la
physique et de ses deux fils et des
affaires qui cherchent des réponses et
puis on va loin thierry ammann est
rendue chemin est encore méconnu
toujours l'inconnu mais c'est pour ça
que moi je me dis pourquoi que c'est pas
possible et chouchou parle un peu de feu
mais pourquoi c'est pas ce qui était
qu'il nous le keynote grande quête
humaine à tous genres on a vraiment pas
beaucoup et longtemps sur le fait qu'on
est sur une crosse qui flotte dans
l'infini le alors que ça pourrait être
la base woodley
avez-vous sayan coutelas dié partie du
livre on désinfecte ah non mais ça c'est
pas cette curiosité leur propre forme
qui devrait nous habitait depuis le
primaire l'ouest comptant premières
années puis on écrit à mme lagarde
on flotte sur une roche on comprend pas
pourquoi peas et que ça devrait être
juste
ce qui nous arrive on travaille tous a
trouvé cette réponse je trouve que moi
je trouve que c'est ce ben moi même tous
qu'ils se sont séparés sur les dialogues
moi j'arrivais à l'école l'alchimie puis
je faisais le notre père en train mais
non séparés vous je trouve qu en tant qu
est pourquoi qui on est on sait qu'au
lycée c'est des bateaux pour 6 on
traverse on a découvert le puits on
trouverait quelque chose mais non le cap
au leste et pour l'argent c'est l'argent
mais les épices comme dans les salles
une bonne raison non oui je suis sûr que
si c'est une petite partie de la
population qui est cet intérêt le alors
qu'on pourrait les implanter dans le
cerveau de tout le monde on dirait cette
curiosité alors que moi j'étais comme
jésus c'est vrai que c'est fait christie
c'est au my god
atamna petit en train de me dire qu'on
est sur une partie que d'explosions qui
travaillent qui voyagent tranquillement
au ralenti dans l'infini piqué ça que
tout le monde soit je sais pas on dirait
que ça m'aurait pas dérangé de changer
mes cours de religion pour des cours de
physique quantique mettons les
introductions et la fonction physique
alors que sur la table un cours
d'histoire que cours de religion ce
texte durcit examinons mais j'aimerais
les gens à partir de tous les jours jean
bégin deux potes non je doute de tout ce
que je n'ai pas expérimenté mais c'est
je vois c'est ça c'est cette baisse des
notions londres et contre est tous un
peu plus unie comme comme humain si on
était tous investis de sentiment d'être
terriens plus que ce genre contre plus
d'une histoire
on est prêts on est poli l'instit
sentiment qu'on est des terriens les
investisseurs ce qu'on a connu dans nos
petites frontières et inventer chacun
ça s'est passé cette ligne ou qu'on la
connaît depuis un camion est même pas
trace et physiquement c'est sur une
carte mais le board se tue pas vous
n'êtes pas même quand c'est non c'est ça
qui te pique je l'aimé tant que bon
c'est est utopique mais tu n'es sur la
terre la tête à partir je veux dire tout
devrait être tout le monde voir qu'on
peut appraître et vous et moi j'ai une
étoile en passant l'a imaginé que j'ai
une autre planète qui acheta même étoile
s'est passé juste ou non mais c'est pas
un métier comment ça on peut acheter des
étoiles non mais comment 6 le territoire
tout ce pour quoi qu'on en dise et j'ai
l'impression de sunnites tout est à toi
voir que des plages privées voire on
dirait que l'expérience humaine hélico
complètement corrompue par le fait qu'on
puisse avoir des affaires il ya des gens
qui méritent de la police jose wifi seul
j'ai préco universités sûr
l'étude de la bible qu'il en faut
toujours à ces déductions qu'on faisait
des jo quant aux séductions puis on lit
plus on essaie de comprendre que six à
dix puis j'ai compris ben jaffar parce
que c'est pas toutes les civilisations
qui avait est non d'expansion des
profits de détruire de l'anapi tout
m'appartient t les autres quand on
arrive ici était en harmonie
veux-tu un miroir voici un fusil ok tu
lis aussi une des premières choses qui
est écrit que je le dis pas tiens je
vais répéter une évolution qui est écrit
dans un jardin dans un premier chapitre
si tu es je t'écris turenne sur les
animaux sur la nature ce tatouage fais
ce que tu veux comme notre identité
parce que tu y mets ton on est humains
sont achetés suspens encore le loisir la
région piti d'épicés principe c'est
vraiment si c'est comme ça se fait 2000
à qu'on se fait dire tout ce site à
partir parce que c'est toi qui ressemble
à du souci toit du sétois après du site
what i way fait le tout soit à partir
fait que dati gauthier et qu'on se
faisait le droit te le droit d'être
mérite d'avoir des affaires aussi tu as
le droit le droit d'avoir
j'ai le droit d'avoir ce gt j'ai le
droit d'avoir deux charges est long on
n'est plus capables d'augmenter cette
espèce de droit la possession le non
plus on dirait que tous nos effets liste
on est félicité par le droit d'avoir des
affaires mais ça a ruiné la planète le
seul jeudi
mais je comprends pas qu'on ait le droit
de cumuler compulsivement des affaires
passe parce que ce qu'on doit nommer
m'étais se mettant ce concept là ça va
papa rencontre de l'autre idée de dire
tune est ici fait que toute la partie
doit-on accès à tout mais non il y avait
le droit ou non mais oui mais tu aurais
le droit je dire d'avant thorel douala à
l'accès à la à la rivière à l'ast parc à
cette forêt mais la limite de droit ou
non mais si tout le monde y appartient à
personne
fac faut juste apprendre à vivre avec
cette affaire le plus ou moins de
conflits ça peut créer plus de conflits
peut-être et ça crie plus de conflits
pour les gens qui étaient habitués
d'avoir toutes leurs affaires à un autre
puis qu'ils sont beaux c'est sûr mais
moi des fois je me dis ah pook genre
mettons moi j'ai pas de drill l'eau qui
n'est pas tendre il t'envoie oui mais
pourquoi il ya poyer qu'une drilles par
hull j'ai pas besoin d'avoir une dribble
je cogite drilles pas tous les jours
quelque chose et j'ai une échelle
mettons moment c'est de cette espèce
d'affaires la nécessité de possession à
soi pour tout à coup j'en ai besoin moi
j'ai tellement de stocks que j'ai pas
besoin dit que on dirait que je pense
que ce sentiment là de partage puis le
studio ça frétille plus de conflits je
pense pas que ça ferait plus de conflit
si on est on été élevé avec cette espèce
de notions de partage le haut lieu de
cette notion de peut devenir qui tu veux
dans vite et tu peux faire ce que tu
veux si je pense que ça nous ça courait
ne perd que de se faire dire à chaque
individu qu'on était dont 20 spéciales
qu'on fait devenir ce qu'on voulait et
les pieds alors qu'il faudrait que ce
qu'on se dise si on peut ensemble
devenir quelque chose de beauté c'est
pas ma mission c'est andrée que chacune
de nos vies et on lui accorde trop
d'importance alors que les vraies
affaires importantes puis qu'on est en
train de perdre c'est ça aussi le
sentiment de communauté si la famille
ces témoins qui voit pas ses amis
passaient trop occupée alors que
pourquoi le but de la vie c'est pas
juste ça de checks et des mines
gfr comment m y mettons mais tant qu'on
reprend l'exemple team justement des
autochtones qui sont vraiment a dit
quitter la rive tapesar yalouz citant
antoine entre tribus et oui parce que
derrière de nous
je pense que la violence latent la
question de pourquoi est ce que le but
c'est pô juste de cech s'est abîmé ton
le trio simplifiée vraiment le truc est
ce que le but peut aussi être des
motivations externe à ce stade par
exemple quelqu'un qui que son but
profond team et on tue déconstruit toute
la société pour la personne sont son but
profond c'est de procurer de 2,2 de
créer du bonheur dans la vie d'autres
gens ça devient une motivation qui
t'amène à faire des choix qui sont par
exemple de devenir humoriste puis de
travailler fort là-dessus sacrifiant ta
vie personnelle pour éventuellement
créer du bonheur dans la vie d'autres
gens mais ça peut être une motivation
aussi légitime que de voir qu'il est en
effet pas que la vie ça devienne juste
qu'il est temps qu'on utilise sont là
pour pour simplifier un système qui plus
plus complexe en fait c'est que moi
c'est l'éloge de la productivité que je
voudrais qu'on slack dessus pour pouvoir
postuler que nos amis c'est jean que les
gens sont vacants la semaine de 4 jours
est pourquoi pour la semaine de trois
jours gens que tout le pays même le lan
et de six mois c'est comment on
travaille tous six mois par hanning kg
oui en alternance s'est inventé c'est
aussi le travail si tout est utile on
pourrait vraiment et après ça des
métiers de passion comme je dis moi
c'est pas un job et que j'ai le ses
hobbies qui est devenu un travail ça
après ça se calcule mal des semaines de
trois quatre jours c'est des fois je
travaille beaucoup des fois je travaille
pas puis on dirait que j'aimerais que ça
s'applique à tous les métiers cette
affaire lortie cette espèce de sentiment
de liberté qu'on est là les deux
semaines qu'on travaille peau d'après ce
oui cette espèce de sentiment
galvanisant d'adrénaline demande du
jeune homme n occupé pendant deux autres
semaines
mais moi je ne comprends pas qu on est
en quarts cannes et l'humain dans la vie
c'est ce travail plus que tu ville pour
vivre
quand aurait même pu tant l'énergie de
vivre parce que tu vas être traitée puis
j'en dis pas que les retraités on peut
l'énergie de vie est ce que je dis c'est
que la vis en foot en profite tout le
long faut pas que tu as tu m'étonnes un
bloc le travail puis le cash qui a
cumulé pour pouvoir vivre
je comprend pas moins qu'on soit poignée
dans ce mode lte et je sais pas si
quelqu'un fume et aider là dedans leur
métier c'est ce qui est des balancements
c'est sûr que si je pense qu'on
travaille trop en général ça c'est
officiel mais n'empêche que pour pouvoir
pour que tu puisses tu lis tes amis il
quelqu'un d'autre il faut qu'ils
travaillent ça ce que tu aimais tant la
bouffe que tu vas manger qui va faire
que tu vas me tais puis c'est pour ce
qui est des métiers nautisme et ont
chacun a sa petite branche pis ensemble
on construit quelque chose parce qu'il
fallait qu'on start-up linge faire notre
bout face tout tout seul on aurait pu le
temps pour terry gou amis non exactement
sauf qu'en même temps le on le fait
faire part du monde à l'autre bout du
monde
je veux dire peut-être qu on aurait
besoin de moins de linge si on le
faisait faire si je pense qu'il faudrait
avoir besoin de se rendre compte qu'on a
besoin de moins de linge se rend compte
qu'on a besoin de moins de choix
l'épicerie se rende ici c'est juste de
tout diminué pour avoir plus de temps
parce qu'au final si ce qui c'est cela
l'important aussi le temps merci pas
blondy le temps c'est de l'argent
effectivement dans notre monde le temps
c'est de l'argent parce que tout accepte
de donner de son temps pour faire plus
d'argent mais de moins en moins de temps
pour le dépenser cet argent le alors que
si on avait tous le sentiment d'avoir
besoin de moins de choses si on aurait
plus de temps pour les affaires un peu
plus
mais la vraie vie c'est à dire passer du
temps avec les gens propres
si c'est ça c'est juste que oui il faut
quelqu'un d'autre travail pendant que
toi tu filmes et amman et c'est tout tu
travailles pcistes personnes le chill
pis on travaille tous un petit peu moins
parce qu'on a tous un petit peu moins
besoin d'en faire un peu tous tu ne peux
souffler un peu plus tôt genre je suis
flabbergasting par les multis
possibilité de choses à avoir pitié
j'hésite vraiment besoin - d'un nano
danville
non mais ouais j'ai permettons mettons
qu'on prend l'exemple facile d'un avocat
et kiki qui vient du mexique kid
nécessite une énergie qu'on lui demande
c'est une affaire myristique nécessite
beaucoup de même pas à devoir amener ces
sites et l'énergie au temps au temps
puis les conditions du monde qui les
ramasse son misérable aussi est ce qu'on
a au québec notons le besoin d'avocat
l'épicerie est et puis en fait besoin de
la question besoin on peut on peut aimer
ce besoin en plus d'ailleurs que j'aime
croire que l'humain qui habite dans une
dans un climat quelconque puis une
situation géographique quelconque au
besoin de se nourrir des affaires que ça
tu fournis les nutriments dont on a
besoin c'est minuterie c'est les enfants
qui survivent dans ce kimono abbas et je
sais pas si c'est vrai mais c'est sûr
qu'on manquerait peut-être un petit peu
de vitamine d qui parle beaucoup d'une
web qui survivent depuis des semaines sa
fac on n'a pas besoin d'avocat
on n'a pas besoin d'ananas on a peu
besoin de mangue
c'est bon c'est délicieux saifon que
quelqu'un puisse goûter dans sa vie
faudrait sac ou de vieilles pièces
malheureusement mais encore là ça serait
ça serait comme juste les riches
pourraient se payer de la demande de
l'avocat ça ce serait une autre espèce
d'affaires d'injustice les boutiques et
oui exactement
mais en même temps limite non je pense
qu'on a pas besoin d'avocat même une
bonne anglais banan s'impose sinon plus
on en a pas besoin et dans le fond que
c'est qu'on pourrait mettre jusqu'à mais
je suis d'accord avec cette scpi une des
affaires qui le plus un témoin depuis
que je m'intéresse plus accusés
puis une zafour les plus intéressantes
c'est le cuisiner selon la saison selon
qu'ils sont disponibles ici
puis une fois que tu tchèque pour vrai
qu'est-ce qui est disponible at-elle
dans l'année c'est oui évidemment dans
les saisons estivales il ya plus de
choix ouais mais à l'année longue
mais tu as accès à des affaires à
l'année longue c'est qu'ils sont ici pic
et pic avec une alimentation balancer
tout facilité facilement capable de
nourrir que de ce1 100% de s'en tirer
dit l'impact environnemental exor mais
ma fille ça coûte moins cher ça coûte
moins cher puis la luta phase et qu'on
dit mettons ya certaines affaires que tu
achètes qui sont qui viennent du québec
que plus chère d'un courage à 4 mais il
ya de la fac ou de peluches assure que
le truc c'est que si la demande augmente
l'offre augmenté et on est capable
d'avoir un prix compétitif avec ce qui
vient d'ailleurs qui s'est tellement pas
normal que ce qui pousse ici finissent
par coûter plus cher
il ya quelque chose qui marche pas parce
que ça veut dire que nous duo de genre
notre belle morale occidentale nord
américaine avec un mois mais nous on
veut payer les tromper les gens et un
salaire minimum pour leur travail le
travail sur quelqu'un ça vient non c'est
sur le central sous traitants sais pas
si nous fait un grand sens use on est
comme on dit ici il ya des pays gens ils
soupèsent vraiment quittera lundi compte
sur des gars là c'est comme moi mais ce
qu'il produit imaginez maintenant qu'on
un monde ce qu'on consomme juste locales
d' imaginons mais quand tu vois un
voyage mettons exact imagine comment tu
vis c'est son plus long voyage à travers
à travers toutes les sensations que topo
chez vous tous exact comment tu peux
expérimenter vraiment la culture 420 au
mexique qui mangent une guacamole
mettons avec des torchons maïs ou puis
que l'auto jamais je ne veux pas
susciter une réelle mais cambrai de
vrais hommes et sont très corrects on
pourrait s'en voir ici
dans le sillage de tortillas et comme
tout art essai non mais c'est vrai que
en plus je me posais beaucoup de
questions sur le voyage j'aime beaucoup
voyagé puis je trouve que ce cd mesurer
à quel point on peut voyager le même
peut-être pas ce moment d'en parler mais
je pense que c'est ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que les choses voyage - mais que
les gens voyagent et de continuer à
voyager ici c'est ce que ben point
qu'elle est juste un voyage peu plus le
mécanisme un voyage mais quand on voyage
- de chaud aussi les choses voyage
tellement dans l'argent environnementale
moi je me suis intéressé beaucoup et
c'est à cette question là puis la chose
que je serai pas prêt à mettre mon
impact environnemental sur la planète la
seule chose que je serai pas prêt à ses
créances et les voyages parce que je
trouve que ça t'amène beaucoup plus de
positif que négatif
puis que en ayant en allant voyager en
allant voir d'autre part du monde qui se
portent pas de la même façon au
changement climatique ça sensibilise
beaucoup plus à réduire son impact à la
maison puis puis c'est sûr mais je pense
que je pense que ce se serait la chose
que moi je réponds pas de modifier
mettons mais je pensais que je serais
pas capable de modifier ce - meetic ans
est arrivé tout au mois de mars le filon
gens j'ai réussi dans ma tête à me dire
mettons qu'on peut plus voyager jamais
c'est dommage mais je penche correct
mais non j'ai six sauf que geruge parce
que moi j'ai l'anip assisté je te porte
cette semaine en voyage sais pas je
parte en europe les clés j'avais
vraiment le profond sentiment que
c'était peut-être la dernière fois que
je pouvais partir je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai en même temps j'ai toujours
l'impression que la fin nous guette nos
facultés
ça rajoute un petit à chaque journée
mais je mets genre au mois de mars avril
mai cheka pas non je voudrais que si je
change de paramètres dans mon cerveau
puis que le voyage n'est plus une option
je suis capable de m'adapter but de
de l'accepter c'est son flow on est homo
d'octobre
c'est juste c'est sûr juste l'idée que
comme de me direz peut-être que si je
n'avais jamais goûté un problème là de
me dire plus jamais dans ma vie je vais
pouvoir aller baigner dans la mer chaude
et privilégie encore la planète plus pas
et jouir de ce fait exporter des fois
j'essaie de m'en départir de ces espèces
de com - je pourrais pas me passer de
vous et je pense que ces privilégiés que
c'est pour le trot bénéfique bien
portants annoncé sur ces noms c'est ce
débat là dessus
100% que c'est bénéfique mais ce qui
m'étonne ce qui se passe que tu as
privilèges est-ce que ce qu'on se voit
forcé de pau ont joué sur le profilage
mettons pas vers moi le nombre
d'assiettes que mes parents m'ont fait
venir un besoin virginie a des enfants
qui mangent pas fait que j'espère que
j'espère que ce parce qu'on a un
privilège qui il faut le savoir de ce
sommet mais ouais non je sais pas la
bonne réponse finale c'est ce qu'ont
fait se sentir mal
la question c'est ce que est ce que en
utilisant ce privilège là tu empêches
d'autres chiens de de s'en approcher ou
des pouvoirs l'expérimenté terme et on
exprime t de dire est ce que moi de
faire un voyage dans les chais pas au
mexique
est-ce que ça empêche quelqu'un de faire
quoi que ce soit d'autre ce que je dis à
quelqu'un
non mais ce que les balancements qui
fait que toi tu vis dans une cité qui te
permet de faire ce voyage le débat
lancement est-ce que c'est chez pas le
voyage
ça va contribuer à réduire le débat
lancement fait qu'il fasse le voyage
mais parce qu'en plus je devais mettons
là je m'étonne et d'amérique est mon
chevalet dans des pays à part soit en
europe qui sont plus - le web
reese et donc qui peut contribuer à
l'économie de ce pays le reggae dans
l'argent à quelqu'un ça va contribuer au
système américain qui a soulevé la foule
mettez à jesse lee à l'impact
environnemental qui dans les choux
mathis non sinon ça que tu participes au
tourisme et à précieux qu'est ce qui
fait que ce pays le et défavorisées
ultime ace qui participent à soutenir
nous notre mode de vie parce que d'une
autre façon l'exploitant indique aussi
que souvent ce qui se passe maintenant
je fais un j'encourage le tourisme mais
ultimement on est quand même la cause du
malheur de pays sous-développés
passionnés
lorsque je parle des fois j'aimerais
retourner étudier plus longuement à
l'université et un complice et curiosité
le vtt philosophe s'est résumé pourquoi
un village pendant huit ans mais mon
métier ma tante et ont dit les enfants
sont tous philosophes le t on jamais
perdu t on à manille et le poteau monde
ça en vaut surtout parce qu'on est tous
un peu philosophe comme tous ces
questions le t4 à pourquoi si pourquoi
seulement ce qui est épars décrit comme
tu comme rester là ouais les amis sans
dégâts
non mais non mais t'es cool d'entre eux
ne se fait pas exprès jp c'est cool
c'est quand même parce qu'on dirait que
pour moi j'accepte ma le fait qu' on
accepte la réalité si facilement c'est
pas la peine absurdité comprennent pour
l'équipe conquest c'est trop peur d'y
penser trop longtemps et si c est juste
qu on soit pas capable de déconstruire
des affaires qu'on a inventé de
désinventer des affaires qui ont
finalement nuit parce que c'est une
montée ça fait un charles ii peut-être
penser plus avoir de sacs en plastique à
l'épicerie familiale il ya des sacs en
papier il ya quand même on est quand
même non non moi je peux pas à prendre
un appartement mon sac à l'épicerie team
oublier trois quatre fois le ton sac tu
m'oublieras plus jamais le s'il ya pas
de solution à l'epci ya pas d'autres se
désole n'y en a pas de solution mais
oublie la de trois fois pour la forme si
on dirait qu on veut pas brusquer les
humains mais on veut pas fou qu'il
désapprouve tranquillement les choses
n'ont cessé la catastrophe
j'ai l'impression que les autoroutes des
chemins entre mettons le capitalisme
nous coule ou nous sauf téléthon soit on
dit faut que le système puis on retourne
vivre vraiment de manière simple le tpiy
de piloter de justement douter de
décroissance scolaire extrême ou en jeu
par la science l'innovation autour des
solutions à nos problèmes qui règlement
climatique piquer comme boum puis on vit
dans une utopie tous les deux ont été
gérés j'ai l'impression que la seule
chose qui va faire qu'on revienne à
quelque chose de plus simple c'est on se
prenait pas capables ensemble de tous
décroître
ok je tiendrai qui vont décider de la
fin du monde essayais de paul farmer
usher sur le dos du manque de croissance
il faut qu'ils pour décroître faut que
les entreprises au dessus faut qu'il
faut que les dieux les entreprises
et changent leur espèce de mode de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire faut que
tout des crocs des croire changeront pas
sur son plus jeune fils alors que le nom
et la farnce recyclage peut aller a noté
peace river road et chez le psy correct
le petit geste individuel métissée au
dessus qu'il faut que ça change pile
affaire qui va faire que ça va changer
au dessus j'ai l'impression c'est un
cataclysme une catastrophe naturelle ces
genres l'écroulement on dirait qu'il
vous faut qu'on se rendre jusqu'au bout
pour que ça change pour de vrai
comme on le voit avec l'ati la pandémie
là on est arrivé à un point où est-ce
qu'on a pas le choix de tout arrêter au
mois de mars là on a comme plus le choix
alors alors que l'on ne ratifie oui mais
là parce qu'on aime on dit qu'on n'avait
pas le choix
mais dans ce cas là on aurait été
capable de le faire sans arriver à un
espèce de paul choix de même comme une
tendinite est encore drôle le dur on est
arrivés collectivement décroissance mais
les plus riches ont continué à faire si
seulement triste mais ça fait s'agisse
exacerbée s'ajuste mille problèmes
encore on a un terme étant démission
quand on fait ça ça a diminué ses
mettons pas optique on n'a plus le choix
on n'a pas le choix
sauf que mais effectivement on dirait
qu'il faut ne pas avoir le choix parce
que je me dis moi je pense pas que je
pense pas que de la façon que le système
est fait on doit mettre notre sport sur
la décroissance mais non journée
j'adresse port sur le fait qu'il y en
aurait plus d'où le nom pendant 50 ans
ou sur le fait que trouver des
alternatives deviennent un enjeu montant
des cessions mais surtout pas aidé
surtout pas sur la bonne conscience sur
genre d'entreprise qu'ils vont se
réveiller un matin à spa la bonne chose
le de toujours vouloir plus fin plus
d'argent pape au capitalisme vert ce que
c'est ce titre en frais mais moi je
pense qu'il faut que ça n'aille pas le
droit de faire certaines affaires s'est
focalisée sur moi je pense que je crois
un jour du capitalisme ultra glam moi je
crois pas moi je pense que je suis dit
dans socialiste le dire je pense que si
c'est pas être comme des jeux s'est
passé ce fut je pense qu'il faut que
tout soit en cours
ces fautes sont co op il faut pas que
personne puisse faire plus d'argent que
je pense que l'argent est partagé en
parts égales aux gens oxo tiges métier
mais à métro on a sept courts mettant
toit puis vdt amis vous achetez une
immense maison vous êtes des dap et à
toutes visent aussi vous partagez sur
partager tout ça finit que tout les
travaux sa maison tout en toi tout en
toi qui rénovent tout de l'autre qui
fait rien mais tout est à tout le monde
ammonitrates être que choqué où et
comment tu sais c'est l'exemple de che
guevara qui arriva à cuba qui font la
libération thibault puis que ça dit un
système communiste qui lui travaille 80
heures d'un champion dans deux semaines
ils ont vu le taux d'absentéisme
augmenté deux fois à huy en a qui vont
profiter du film et oui mais il ya
toujours même quand il ya du monde qui
profite du fait aussi que tout le monde
qui fait tout le jeu dire les signaux de
l'entreprise le il travaille pourtant
plus depuis que ses employés j'en ai
peur qu y en a pas de réponse on passe
est trop triste
j'en ris libye et c'est tout les paradis
de ceux-ci vraiment à pau je pense que
le gros couple parasites clair il est
convaincu c'est souvent si les plus
pauvres qui travaillent le plus léger et
le monde qui ont deux trois diables pour
subvenir à leurs besoins mais aussi ce
qui est apprécié ça c'est aux autres
profitent du système d'écouté pas de
quoi tu parles
mais c'est parce que c'est ça on est
tout en raideur cache pas juste que ceux
qui font alors que les gens tout en
haussant vrai que ses pensées et hi hi
hi hi maintenant vous au savon
qu'est ce que je trouve cool c'est
qu'est mettant ses réflexions aux loups
que tous ces idées là que tout ça
transparaît dans pour travail même temps
ça transparaît d'ankama semble je ne
connais pas le fond je suis en plus
comment tu sembles mettons vivre ta vie
et ta carrière m'étonne c'est parce que
mettons tous les types du mot que tu
fais le type d'or que tu fais les choix
que tu fais bien raison ce tout le temps
motivé par questeur goût de faire sans
de sainte-colombe santé travestis ou ça
se défend trop de compromis ces mots je
suis chez moi - pigeât je veux je veux
jouer la game si je peux être moi même
mais sinon je jouerais pas rien ses
mains j'ai fait et c'est après ce scellé
showbiz il falloir se réconcilier deux
fois ouais septembre à réconcilier c'est
sûr mais je pense que christophe une
vague sur laquelle je suis confortable
c'est à dire que c'est c'est sûr que moi
il ya des affaires que moi je veux aller
me coucher le soir le puits en étant en
étant fier de ce que j'ai fait puis en
trouvant que j'ai été le plus
conséquente possibilité si d'ici là voir
ses discours anticapitaliste peu
apprécié aller faire de la pub
grâce à ce projet ça se peut pas puis
c'est pas content le monde qui vont
faire la pub c'est qu'en ce moment je
suis capable de bien subvenir à mes
besoins en faisant les choses que je
trouve qu'ils ont une certaine qualité
artistique ou kim qui moi me galvanise
si du moment où je suis capable de payer
une épicerie qui est de la lure je vais
en faire la pub dit mais moi je veux pas
moi mais le seul produit que je veux
c'est toi c'est pisser même pas moins
justement c'est ce que je fais et c'est
pour ça que genre j'aime pas tant que ça
existait comme moins à la télé au moins
dans un coin de caste outils le chou le
chemin content que le filet
mais mais ouais on dirait que j'ai en
moi ce que je fais je suis humoriste
suis parfois comédienne puis j'ai tout
ce que je fais je veux que ça me serve
mois ce qui vit un peu à l'encontre
d'ubs ou sentiment de communauté que
j'ai dit non mais j'avais pas personne
que ça doit son nom mais je veux dire
[Musique]
c'est que je veux pas devenir la voix
que j'ai réussi à me crie à une
entreprise pour lui donner une espèce de
de craie de cool de genre où l'humoriste
un petit peu environnementale engagée a
fait nos publics
j'en ai fait des pubs en début de
carrière mais moi mon père fait la pub
ça a payé mon école privée tu
comprendras que mais c'est juste que moi
la publicité je trouve que c'est
vraiment les diables j'ai tout de même
pas ni sur ma peau non je mets pas
toutes dans le même panier ça dépend
pour la campagne du 2e sommet fait
partie des quelque chose oui oui je
pourrais oui sans doute mais même le nom
parce que si je laisse le visage freiner
une pub pour l'entreprise de match m
ce qui fait du linge locale avec lui m
mais même peau mais 16 sacres et un un
problème était nous mettons le podcast
si ce n'était pas de la pub on ne le
ferai plus mais non c'est sûr c'est ce
mec effect je comprends l'idée de dire
mais c'est ça je t'ai dit tapage
moi je ferai la pub et puis même même
est enlisée mettons trop de trèbes
tu aimais tant il y aurait probalement
pas eu trop ce n'est pas depuis nancy
quinquennat s'il écoute pour l'avoir
écouté les dernières semaines qu'un
petit joujou ya quatre rôles 3 fois par
été l'éditeur s'en sortir c'est ce qu'on
vit dans leur monde oui ce qu'il faut
comprendre des affaires qu'on peut pas
s'en sortir
moi c'est sûr je vais être dans des
projets moi j'ai participé à trop
apprécié eux c'est eux que de dire la
puce et le diable alors qu il ya
beaucoup d annoncer qu php mon salaire
au final je compte mais après si c'est
impossible de vivre en autarcie de ce
système des participants même temps
c'est impossible c'est juste que moi
pour justement sentir que je suis d'une
certaine façon conséquente avec le
discours que j'essaie de véhiculer dans
mes blagues je ne peux pas faire une pub
de hesse où je ne rends pas faire une
pub de l'est je ne peux pas faire une
pub d'épicerie de cake
si je veux je veux je ne veux pas après
ça peut-être que dans cinq ans on se
reparle puis je suis comme avec le café
chez steam
[Rires]
peut-être rendu lui mais en ce moment
tant et aussi longtemps que j'ai pas
besoin d'en faire
nous avons enfin mais est-ce que tu
serais prête est ce que est ce que tu
irais le haut du tribun je vais faire
autre chose je veux honnêtement
peut-être je ferai autre chose parce que
j'ai pas moi le show biz le sommet s'il
est content je voulais être comédienne
quand j'étais petit pinana non je suis
vraiment heureux sauf que c'est pas
c'est pas à tout prix non plus ses mots
de la ville c'est une grande suite
d'aventurés locution boit cul dans cinq
angles
c'est pas parce que mais peut-être que
ça soit parce que je suis rendu à ce
bilan qui a plus personne qui veut
demander le port mais c'est aussi
peut-être parce que virgin a décidé que
ça étant telle enseigne aussi j'ai pu
finalement le tipi que c'est ça le sipof
genre n'être ni dimensionnelle avec la
seule ambition de vouloir être connus
pierrelatte élite fall de l'humour si je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens de notre
génération 6 e ou sinon on est les gens
des espèces de mutzig potentia liste
avec plusieurs ambitions puis plusieurs
18 plusieurs possibilités puis moi je
contente le d'être dans cette étape là
de ma vie où est ce que je fais mais je
fais le métier dont je rêvais quand
j'étais petit mais après ma chute à
l'étudier en littérature puis en langue
thiam animé venu le goût de faire la
traduction est venu le goût date
interprète mais aussi enseigner ça a
toujours été quelques chose fois que je
sais pas à tout prix c'est vraiment pas
tout prix facto taille que dans le fond
j'en ferai pas de pub dans 5 ans non
plus je sais 30 du ailleurs à faire
quelque chose d'autre
si encore un moment c'est la ponctuation
si on n'est pas tous d'accord
mais je pense qu on entendre plus ou
presque plus quelqu'un dire moi j'ai
fait 40 ans même place ça arriverait
plus je pense que le monde vont plus
suivent un petit peu les instincts du
moment mais puis on en parlait avec à
dire de moi j'ai un certain malaise avec
l'idée de dire que qui peut faire ce que
sa tante de fonds non c'est vraiment le
feeling que de pouvoir dire ça s'allume
un endroit extrêmement privilégié bibi
qui est un bon exemple
la raison pour laquelle tu fais ce que
tu voulais faire depuis titre une petite
fille parce que tu es ultra talentueuse
dans ce que tu fais je te dire je te dis
pas ça pour te pour te pour tout être
complimenté le hockey mais le point
c'est que je suis sûr qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes filles qui se
disaient qu'ils ont eu ce rêve la maison
mais oui mais après ça de monde qui
disent mettons demandes qui sont dans
une position dans laquelle tu es en ce
moment qui est une position qui met
économiquement ne m'apparaît pas
compliqué à un problème financier
ou est-ce que tu as un bon salaire aussi
été capable d'avoir le privilège de dire
peut-être que j'aimerais ça juste
enseigner ou c'est joli mais c'est
vraiment pas tout le monde de nos
générations qui peuvent dire ceux de
dire suis ta passion fais ce que tu veux
faire au moment où sa tente de le faire
c'est pas tout mais non il se permettre
ça parce qu'il faut que mes neuf autres
vivent les envies de monde qui réalisent
pas leur rêve ça brise mais en même
temps moi il fut un temps où je te colle
à bombay je fais partie de ceux qui
réalisent pas leur rêve puis j'ai quand
même une capacité d'acceptation de soupe
si je travaille et je montais des sites
web pour des clubs de golf pour
l'entreprise de mon oncle bon 20 mars
s'arrête sur
je travaille travaille comme serveuse au
centre bell petit je faisais les
tropiques tout puis jeté comme un bain
aux maisons si je fais partie de mes
rêves c'est vrai que c'est un grand
privilège de moi je suis flabbergasting
finalement faire partie des gens qui ont
réalisé leur rêve je pense à tidiane sy
qui se couchent le soir en rêvant jouer
dans un film avec leonardo dicaprio pi 6
po réaliser ce ok c'est est à dire
métissé la grande majorité lui revient
dans lequel tout le monde vit son rêve
mais on n'a pas besoin d'aucun
instrument ça peut pas dire que de plus
en plus en eux le du monde connu le
petit le mans et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui rêvent d'être
d'être connu plus ça se peut le petit
tout le monde ait connu personne ne le
montrent pas connu crise on veut savoir
si non mais c'est vrai après ce mois ci
et ça marche plus en fait ça c'est que
je privilégie aussi c'est que j'ai
l'impression que si c'est plus ce que je
fais j'ai la chance d'avoir plusieurs
outils putois se réorienter vers quelque
chose d'autre qui l'a la vérité c'est
que mme houle
j'ai tellement aimé ce travaillé comme
serveuse au centre et louis c'était un
rêve
j'étais huit ans hôtesse dans les loges
au centre bell puis des fois je m'ennuie
hne
oui mais c'était à une époque où je
sentais que fo s'accomplir absolument
dans notre métier était alors que
maintenant je fais le métier dans lequel
j'aime accompli puis je suis content
sauf que la visiter c'est que on peut
faire un métier dans lequel on sent pas
con ça complique accompli le travail
nécessaire
pis pour stocker c'est peut-être ça
serait bizarre pour les gens de me
retrouver comme serveuse au centre bell
dans cinq ans parce que j'ai je
travaillais encore au centre bell quand
je t'ai je faisais est saine et le
québec le chat et les conserve ainsi des
fois dans la loge
oui oui mais vous êtes vous bien payé
mais factice mais je retournerais dans
ses dents belotti en même temps en ce
moment est serveuse c'est pas ça doit
pas être d'argent en ce moment c'est pas
fou non mais moi j'ai la chance oui puis
non là c'est à dire que je fais plus de
scènes mais j'ai j'ai des possibilités
des petits contre eux parce que la
culture continue de rouler un petit peu
le team et moi j'écris aussi j'écris sur
des projets fait que sa beauté
je chante je suis chanceux mes chances
j'écoutais les podcasts et puis pendant
à peu près une heure et quart vous
parlez de 6 mais typique c'est moins bon
koudrine espèce de relation amour le
pitch mais maintenant que maintenant qui
privé de la scène est ce que tu
t'ennuies plus que tu aurais passé ou
non dans société
je pense que tout n'est pas un métier
même si ton métier drive amman et ça
devient un métier puisse pas tout le
talent forêt qui est dit dans cette
pièce pse mais est ce que le fait de
refaire leur vie tu te fait réaliser
qu'elles pourront intéresser ou papa
slam
oui puis non je les adore cela c'est
cyclique port à l'intérieur de moi qui
aime se tait genre ne m'ayez corps à
l'intérieur de moi qui aime pas ce
qu'ils m'ont genre ça a l'air
complètement absurde mais parce que
j'aime pas ça mais c'est que ça ça nous
met dans une espèce de drôle ça mène un
stress une pression si je pense y ait
des gens qui adorent la scène qui pipe à
son jeu ses poils sont fait ainsi que
ils remettent pas en question la tension
qui leur est donnée puis aux autres je
sais pas le titre du monde qui sont
comme moi je suis l'objet monsieur bible
au rabais mais moi j'ai toujours le
sentiment un peu d' imposteur puis une
espèce de pression de pourquoi les gens
me vois mais une fois que j'ai sur scène
babin et ça disparaît ce sentiment
religieux comme tanger ou de logement
non mais c'est vrai comme disait au
début quand je pouvais plus faire de
scène pour vrai j'étais pas comme mon
dieu j'ai besoin de retourner à tout
prix mais au début septembre chaari
faire des shows à sept îles et sa côte
nord à port cartier passait-il pied j'ai
tellement une forme que chicago je
mettais jeu en était ennuyé de
sentiments l'hôte et je mens était
ennuyé sauf que je suis contente quand
même que ce soit pas un tout prix à
l'intérieur de moi parce que je pense
que je serai ben trop malheureuse non
ouais je serai bien trop malheureuse
mais j'ai toujours fait des spectacles
j'ai tout et depuis que je suis petit je
fais de l'impro fakih c'est sûr y'a une
part de moi qui aime ça mais il ya une
part de moi vraiment que ça plonge dans
un profond stress puis je n'aime pas
mais je pense c'est le même stress que
ticket mais je suis avant de sauter en
parachute longs mois maintenant j'ai une
grande fan d'arts martiaux mais dans
l'action mais c'est que j'en entends
beaucoup des combattants d'hier comme je
l'aï sommes battre mais je suis j'aime
tout les jours de ma vie sauf la journée
une fois que son gré c'est ça y est
terrifié c'est un email
une fois qu il le fait il ya gagné un
sentiment de fierté quand il ya un
george qui aiment ça parce que sinon il
n'y aurait pas fait toutes les démarches
pour ça jusqu'ici puis à l'autre je suis
comme voyons georges que si puis moi je
veux pas comparer un combat contre non
parce que le scot il ya d'églises je me
fais pas mal un lieu d'échangés
il ya des blessures des gommes et un
sens similaire peut-être mais jean hp
sort que faire une job qui baume c'est
aussi pire que tout
et ce côté mais en plus quand c'est beau
c'est non seulement quant au mal
physiquement mais tous savent ou non
c'est pas du tout la même affaire mais
je pense que c'est parce que
l'adrénaline
chacun sa manière d'aller chercher son
adrénaline six mois ça passe pas par me
faire frapper puis frappe piquée que
d'autres mais aux autres si ça s'est
tellement extrême que ce soit la façon
d'aller chercher leur adrénaline moi
c'est un peu plus soft
mabri aussi soft du parti tout seul
devant des centaines de personnes de
livry pu espérer que le monde ne se
posant pas si sauf mais en même temps
mais si ça mais c'est ce pot soft mais
c'est ce jeu capable c'est ce que j'aime
faire il faut je fous je m'en rappelle
parce que des fois j'ai vraiment pu goût
de le faire on dirait il ya vraiment
deux virginie tout le temps et à la
virginité il a virgin hill qui est comme
dans vraie vie est comme mon genre
comment jugez vous évoquez je veux même
bouquet au fringe à edimbourg et un mois
de show à voir pour les von euw et la
virginie qu'il faut qu'il y ait bondi
pourquoi j'ai vu pourquoi j'ai fait du
judo mais n'est pas inspiré l'allergie
qui arrive là bas qu'est comme poker un
jeu nommé banane mais énormément c'est
une fois que c'est sur scène y sur moi
qui en a rien été
ouais mais si c'est pas virginie
virginie après comme on dit jean aimé ça
mais le moment était sur scène c'est
t'as pas le choix le tout et peach et le
fait que tu es comme garder la gagne je
suis bonne là dedans puis je me fais
rire pour vous avoir pu temps si vous
m'aidez que je retombe je ressors de
cinq champs aux mains si je suis
etes-vous multi vous avez pas multi une
personne vous
vous qui dit fête la musique sans
caractère apparemment sans ce qui est
chouette mon cerveau compartimenté en
plusieurs hier
je monte un show puis aujourd'hui je ne
crois pas que ça quitté quand tu es
quand tu es sur sign jézéquel
extrêmement tu joues le lecteur
principalement quand tu es sur scène
pour dominique
écrit-il tranquille et accepter quand
une personne est morte et je fais pas
les doors un sentiment de ne pas être
jusqu'à moi je peux jouer tranquille ou
à sauver bâti ça dépend du contexte des
fois je vais être dangereux vivement
recrue occulte m j'étais de mauvaise foi
je vois c'est la présence visible non
mais web des fois t'es fictive ajouté
john une soirée où est ce que c'est les
piquets on est choqué que cette histoire
est survolté et d'autres fois je suis
gay qui accompagne l'auteur qui chante
depuis que je te fais mes affaires
il ya des fois que je tends complète
paranoïa ah ouais je suis juste des fois
je suis sur scène puis c'est pourquoi je
fais ce métier là oui c'est un bon sac
l'épaule en quinté comme pochoir non ça
m'arrive d'évacuer un appareil en mode
va cultive à toutes les modes culte à
wazemmes et un débarquement de diester
faut le bon finale ana mais toi tu
aideras ta tête tu es le blanc était et
je peu ça te fait sauter l'espèce de
cathy pu dans le moment présent mais
c'est jamais bon je pense mais n'ont
jamais su vraiment jamais le tout juste
au regard de certaines choses pour ça
c'est horrible qu'ils en aient trop des
fois ça arrive
j'ai fait beaucoup d'infos peut les
pousser sur le sida on a eu la pire idée
dans le caucus mais c'est pas le choix
faut bien et puis faut pas te regarde
pas ce que déclare peter graves s'est
quand même pourquoi je suis en train de
faire une écurie zombies voyons ça
tombait par rapport à ça y est sony qui
est tombé
question la première c'est la meilleure
mais dès qu'il sort de toi qui te
regardent un moment faut arriver mais
c'est une des choses que je trouve ce
jeu parce que si on a plus de l'accepter
ou titre a couru vers le dtp
complètement dans le moment j'en arrive
vous arrive pas souvent mais quand ça
arrive des fois ça arrive à d'autres
maintenant la faute au camping chanteuse
gaza c'était un match un point c'est ça
mais on est toujours que c'était plus
dur envers soi-même que que ouais mais
après ça moi des fois jusqu'aux membres
de sa famille espère que je commençais
mes amis qui me protège machine ça
arrive ce décalage entre la perception
wiki vraiment ce qui s'est passé pour de
vrai à 100% mais c'est drôle parce que
je pensais que tient à force de
répétition ça devrait devenir juste un
automatisme raison de la scène mais de
garder le trac couleurs
c'est le sentiment de servir en chine
est arrivée sur un style typique de
cannes je pensais pas que c'était
quelqu'un qui avait tant de sufi cayenne
afa qui me dérange les sociétés où il
suffit que des détails qui fait que nous
mettons je fais une erreur comme dans la
première toune passe à petit par dessus
les sétois je tiens y'a pas de soirée
qu'elle s'est même public le public te
sorte de toit et public mais ça se voit
mais tu sais quoi le public parce que
ultime en faudrait pas que je laisse
pouvoir l'eau publique andré métayer il
ya quand même un partage d'énergie en
stand-up le pire en tendant toutes les
heures la scène je pensais quand même
c'est moi je donne quelque chose qu'il
faut je reçoive quelque chose pour que
la prochaine fois que je donne mais au
début début de la tournée quand j'étais
en rodage j'étais vraiment plus
facilement déstabilisé par le public
parce que parce que l'espèce de wii ou
d'énergie que je sentais pas ce que ça
collait pas à marcher poti mais plus
j'ai fait le soul plus genre c'est je
suis vraiment devenu maître de l'énergie
qui se promène dans la salle tipi puis
je suis toujours stressé mais c'est des
fois il ya un stress qui est un peu
paris paralysant maintenant il ya un
stress inquiétant mais il ya un bon
stress aussi là qu'il en est des bus
début de la tournée quand j'avais pas le
shoot et au final finale c'était un
stress un peu paralysant qui fait que tu
performes pas ton meilleur parti mais
c'est devenu une espèce de stress comme
kate est capable de transformer en
excitation si on dirait que le stress
puis genre l'excitation positive ça fait
quand même les mêmes un peu les
sentiments l'intérieur puis j'ai
l'impression que par ton cerveau tu es
capable de switches de stress leur
embauche triste mais des fois mais mais
bref avec eux l'expérience puis en
faisant de plus en plus mon show le
stress est devenu un bon stress quand
j'ai aucun syndicat ne pas stresser le
cash trojan ou cheval fois je suis pas
bon des fois je deviens stressé de pas
être assez stressés et fax c'est comme
un peu la solution à son problème parce
que non mais si je posterai ces
pathologies comme le ya un problème
parce que moi qui a enregistré six focus
le tiche focus qui mais pour quoi que ce
soit encore le stress qui est comme un
stress de doute c'est le doute par ali
dans le doute qui fait que tout remettre
en question faut que ça soit un stress
de juste comment mon dieu j'espère
qu'ils vont aimer ça a été puis je sais
pas mais je pense pour toujours être
précis du moment où tu es plus stressés
même si ça fait vingt ans quand il fait
ça il ya plus il ya plein de vie mais
après ce vote les gens c'est un jeu face
au fait que je suis
une soirée que ça marche moins tu
t'appelles que non je porte
j'ai agi seul mais je prends pprt tout
du moins c'est le public qui disent rien
compris mais oui le la première phase
c'est la preuve que c'est la fin du day
2 du congrès c'est le public son aise
enfin compris qu'ils aillent aux hôtes
et après ce mois ou semaines
si je me sens une nourrir à ce jour mon
juge sujet hyper date with lions qui ont
haï search pour bones pas drôle factice
pas en paix mais sa passe est capable de
marmande 2 prend la décision injuste que
malgré toi ou à l'erreur
tu fais de l'humour alternatif le design
tombe c'est savard est venu dans ce sens
qu'il faut c'est ça va arriver que tim
est on j'étais petit je t'attendais se
dotant droite il ya des mécanismes que
tu sais que tu fais tu l as far away
savary qui se pose est que tout le
groupe pas non plus 4 pouces se tait
c'est sûr qu'il est public ticket qui
songe propres et puis même et on pense
tu que le québec est prêt à savoir un
style d'humour non genre et guillaume
wagner aurait pas de carrière puis
j'aurais pas de carrière puis j'avais à
dire a dit busti fait quelque chose de
thé et je pense qu'un moyen de réussir à
faire quelque chose qui s'inscrit
quelque part dans le mainstream mais qui
est cunti moi j'aime pas se dire les
gens sont pas prêtes et les gens sont
bien prêts à recevoir ce qu'on leur sert
6,6 après so you think you when i was
here
votre couple désolé mais ses méthodes et
aux states où met-on est un gros marché
du co2 le plus gros sur ton humour niche
et c'est ça qui si on ne bat c'est une
population un petit peu plus réduit
c'est le même monde vont aller voir
plusieurs modèles pense qu'on peut
trouver sa niche c'est juste que c'est
moi maintenant je veux pas vendre cinq
cent mille billets non plus le moins que
j'ai commencé ma tournée que juste pour
rire puis j'étais flab le gast et la
brande que ça se pouvait qu avec une
tournée que tu vend 80 mille billets tu
rembourses pâte à prout soit déficitaire
comme s'cusez moi pardon
moi je veux je veux je vous parlais à
30000 personnes en mettant mes trente
mille personnes qui qui vont avoir j'ai
pas envie d'avoir à convaincre tout le
monde de venir mais j'ai l'impression
que mon show et et quand même pour tous
pas pour tout le monde mais quand même
pour tout le monde ce qui touche à tout
le monde la bulle le feu là peu météo si
c'est que souvent mis en scène une coupe
d'automne c'est l'eau et ne compte que
les musicales du tout non je te dis je
sais mais c'est la pub si la différence
entre show qui vend quatre cent mille
billets qu'un choc un ventre en 2010
pour la pub oui pis moi et j'avais dit à
juste pour rire dès le départ comme je
veux je veux pas arrêter par tout le
monde on va je veux réduire l'argent
qu'on met dans le spectacle pour
rembourser la prod le plus rapidement
possible
comme de fait mon choix or peu vendu 30
mille billets et on y entre 25 et 30
mille je pense qu'ils vont m'apprendre
rembourser le savoir ti a qu'un moyen de
faire de l'argent avec un humour un peu
plus niche si on n'est pas dans l'espèce
de d'ambitions démesurées de vendre 450
mille billets puis de pour lui jean
michel anctil outils je sais pas ce que
je veux après ça c'est sûr que je veux
bien parler au plus de monde possible
mais c'est pas non plus à tout prix et y
est demeuré ce que possible c'est qu'est
ce que tu fais ça leur parle mais tu ne
veux pas changer ce que tu fais pour
parler plus souvent passer non non
exactement puis après j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya de plus en plus de
l'humoriste qui arrive qui ont des
propositions originales puis un peu
piqué le monopole de l'humour qui avait
justement juste pour rire qui a
peut-être contribué à homogénéiser ce
qui se fait et puis un genre un numéro 1
gallas et sept minutes qu'il faut que ça
pète il faut que ça pas une spéciale pas
de passion va te mettre des auteurs cet
exploit que les auteurs vont racheter du
texte plus comme je dis je pense aux
nippons humble mais j'ai l'impression
n'y a pas personne que ce que gérer
applique un saut de mettre plus de mot
viol moi aussi
puis je veux pas de ces piques à ses
cheveux longs et moins 10 kg ne sont pas
mais trop tard je les fais pas toi
voyons tout était comme quand même bien
que ça arrive pas pendant deux minutes
c'est moi qui ai décidé de faire ce
genre mais là je pense que justement
avec cette espèce de petit on axait a
tellement de sortes d'humour sont
netflix justement du monde sur et du bio
sont partout on a un accès à l'humour du
monde puis je pense que ça contribue à
peut-être déconstruire cette espèce
d'idée de l'humour qu'est ce que c'est
si genre ah ah ah on est tous parés et
puis c'est plus vrai que c'est vraiment
sorti je vais même passer le ramadan
vers 10h au québec le mot sa peau
vraiment choix parce que c'est vrai
qu'on est un petit bassin une mangue
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas étayé pop je
pense que pour notre population est
quand même à vide du maupuy de rire ne
serait pas sans ce versement
100 % pour les petits bassins de
population qu'on est je trouve que quand
même une offre assez impressionnante de
danse qui fait l'outil commenté li hanté
entendu mots en musique tc les spectres
est quand même super large pour une
micro population fait que fac ci se dit
moi je pense que là en ce moment
l'humour comme n'importe quoi évolue le
pile le monde il borde demande pour rire
de tout l'appui on est on est
tranquillement en train de passer outre
ces espèces de blagues de stéréotypes
d'aimables on déconne kg tu es grosse
pile aa chez raciste mais je n'y a ici
fait que fac 6e avec momo est une niche
eméyé pop nom signifie que si on
apercevait bas à la question est ce que
québec est prêt je pense que le succès
de sa carrière et de la preuve que oui
non mais c'est pas comme ils sont pas
prêts pour moi mais la brillante et
centrait pour moi c'est pauvre sissy
c'est moi non plus je vais danser
peut-être musique hip hop je suis pas
prête à affronter des fois quand ça se
passe pas bien chacun
c'est peut-être moi qui étaient
disponibles qui étaient pas prêts faits
n'étaient pas prêtes à six mois mais
c'est parce que c'est plus facile de
mettre la fois nous apprend du goûter
mais ton d'en être le chemin de 1,6 à 30
du groupe de 10 mineurs faire un show il
ya des jo khl mais tenait là un show
finalement plus un monologue engagé week
un show où est-ce que où est ce que je
vois je serais pas sorti
mais moi je pense à fait
il ya beaucoup de monde qui se
retrouvait pas dans des shows d'humour
conventionnel que les autres ça les a
fait rire salle et ça leur fait du bien
comme chose mort fait du bien aux gens
qu'ils consommaient plus haut niveau
plus conventionnel turbine vont quitter
comme manette pour un show d'humour
parce qu'elle a passé
trente minutes à parler d'un traumatisme
elle était même si ce n'est pas un show
du mot est ce que le stand up se mettant
dans la peau du gros hockey dit mettons
le stand up s'obliger d'être drôle mais
moi je pense que le mot le stand-up
fossat soit drôle mais c'est juste que
faut pas qu'on drôle on pense que c'est
une seule afaria multi multi les enfants
que moi je trouve profondément drôle que
lui voit pas trouvé ça drôle qui est la
voie pas trouvé ça drôle parce que ce
soit mais j'ai l'impression que moi puis
le social j'imagine alan reed et même à
fin mai
la dentiste que j'ai inventé on n'a pas
n'a pas vraiment les mêmes goûts mais je
pense que je pense que je trouve la
question pertinente ne dirai ce que
mettons la nuance en conférence bi stand
up mettons où est ce que tu veux passer
un message que quelque chose à dire
petit lev sur un coin du stand up sur un
site itunes et prend le micro par les
percées dans l'autre extrême dans le
stand-up comique de contes et concerts
gines qui juste d'aider donne un numéro
d'humour pillage spectre complet entre
ces deux affaires deux juridictions mais
moi je pense que c'est juste ou la wii
la conférence c'est la conférence puis
le stand up c'est le stand up après sur
le stand up tu peux choisir de le faire
comme tu souhaites le tout le temps il
ya des moyens d avant je trouve drôle
qu'il ya des gens vont dire c'était plus
une conférence et misc mais moins timide
humoristes préférées c'est beaucoup
débattu de l'histoire qui est un anglais
forme des jantes à rayons manioc et du
budget christine j'ai été nommé à peu
près tous les podcasts italie puis moi
c'est grâce à du monde de même que le
show de nanette j'ai trouvé ça bon là
mais c'est seul c'est ce genre du moule
que je consomme depuis une couple
d'années mais je suis bien heureuse que
ce genre de cholet est percé la coquille
du mainstream pics à elle parla du monde
qu'ils ont qui ont fait au moins god ça
existe ce genre d'humour loti avec moi
je croyais les gens sont comme le
stand-up sais tu sais pas toujours drôle
ouais c'est toujours drôle c'est juste
que c'est pas drôle pour tout le monde
sais je sais tu es le stand-up depuis
des années des années des années ça
reste ça reste un art qui était exercée
par beaucoup d hommes et qui fait fait
rire
mettant une l'homme si hétérosexuels pis
la baisse souvent la femme blanche aussi
le qui se reconnaît la tabaski 2 depuis
le début a consommé lors de ce tome en
baisse on parle aussi moins dans le fond
mais fax et fax est normal que du moment
que le stand up change de ce petit
chemin le monde et comme beurre au spot
ce pas drôle ou pas du stand up mais où
met-on stand up monsieur il faut il la
faisait pas rire
la jeune queer chez elle kindt et non à
se reconnaissaient pas dans son examen
de la prostate fac pour elle c'était une
conférence ton affaire puis le cas on
arrive avec un show comme nanette pialat
gatsby déconstruit un peu l'espèce de
l'humour conventionnel mais les éléments
d'accord mais ça c'est pas de l'humour
mais il ya plein de monde qui pensait
que l'otan n'était pas de l'humour sont
comme bon ce c'est mon humour aussi
parce que je peux je pense je pensais
que mon analyse non mais absolument pied
au même titre que tout ce que tu as
écouté comme film c'est à wengen ben si
tu vois un film
auteur ou un film étrange et ont tout
fait ce coup du cinéma non c'est ça
exactement mais existe plus important
exact un peu plus pour ceux voilà voilà
la république pour le tout se choisit
way est ce que des projets de télé qui
s'en vient de se tourner fans un
plaignant c'est quoi ton pour la
troisième saison de true cent en janvier
mais non j'ai pas mal en ce moment
j'écris sur des tuiles à l'ultime saison
oui c'est l'ultime saison est déjà sorti
sur tout et villa n'est pas aussi mais
le ressort à la à la tv tv en janvier
mais sinon j'ai des petites affaires
laissées en secret ça c'est pourquoi
mais ce couple mais je travaille sur de
petits projets mairie non j jerry n'en
font qu'un seul nom mais scarlett parce
qu on flotte dans les philippines
non mais j'ai j'écris j'écris sur toute
la partie lui en ce moment mais ce nom
sinon c'est quoi ma vie donc c'est jouer
ta tour n'était pas finie le cas que non
il reste l'église show qui devait finir
où s à fait achevé je devais finir le 11
juin à saint eustache
c'est pas le pire parmi nos sens que je
décolle non maman bel ami arnaud soli
quelle vitesse après 6 mai
au moins c'est ici
mais non même rester king date qu'ils
ont leur place est certes qui donges en
effet de 4 dans steam en jaune 17 mois
c'est sony fait 4 qui m'en reste roi qui
normalement devraient arriver jeanjean
under en janvier puis en avril mai
advienne que pourra laurent tu diras due
à un show est peint tout moi je pense
que j'ai vraiment pas j'ai vraiment pas
d'attachement aux choses mais j'aime pas
voir le temps passer pas seul à faire
qui me fait de la peine c'est icomos et
la fin de quelque chose mais c'est pas
le chou en tant que tel parce que moi ce
show le jpost cette année de le faire je
l'aimé encore puis fier parce que je
pense que c'est un show que dans cinq
ans je veux pas honte de ce que j'ai dit
il aujourd'hui je regarde donc ma
première tournée j'ai fait des matches
avec mariama ne pas capter mais mais non
je suis j'ai bien hâte au prochain ti g
j'avais commencé à écrire le prochain
quand c'est arrivé plus urbaine leur
écriture faire parce que parce que la
vie a changé un petit petit mais mais
non je suis comme contente juste arrivé
au bout de 2 juillet devenu ce qu'il y
avait à devenir je suis bien fière de
l'accomplissement mais logis haute de
d'avoir une espèce de petit feu
intérieur pour une nouvelle affaire de
passer par les étapes de du stress des
gens aux mondiaux ce qui provoquait ce
que je tenterai par le haut-magistrat
méditation owen trouver de nouvelles jo
qui le dit dans la création de quelque
chose d'autre
si je suis triste je suis vraiment
patrice bétail que la dernière je voyais
comme la fin d'une étape mais lorsqu'on
me
nos chapelles ou est ce que tu le capter
ou de capter on soit en moi je les
pauvres moutons tout le monde l.ch tabac
l'a fait ce qu'on devait capter au mois
de janvier jean qui finalement la
production est ainsi qu'à lille ça coûte
beaucoup de sous capter la maman piloter
pour remettre la captation jetait pour
faire des dates amant une date à
montréal au mois de juillet pour la
dernière entre ce qu'on devait capter
bull puis la captation qui doit avoir
lieu était indu les deux dernières
minutes pour cause de encore les instits
soul qui fait que non il n'existe pas
capté capter on l'avait captées pour
faire des pubs fac c'est vraiment une
captation de base et je suis en train de
m'imaginer est capable d'utiliser 7,4
chance de faire quelque chose d'un peu
de déconstruit mais qu'israël gens de
captation et ce que je veux que ce
cholet existe pour les justes pour moi
c'est parce que le souvenir qui est
ultimement peut-être c'est sûr que
j'aurais aimé ce que soient captés parce
que je trouve que ça s'inscrit bien dans
baichoo quand on trouve en ce moment je
demande sur netflix sur un autre colis
j'ai le jeu lembeye mon spectacle si je
trouve qu'ils passent 20 pi enfin que
j'aurais aimé ça avoir une vraie
captation mais la france et que j'allais
tout écrit par exemple pour le publier
c'est ça le but de faire de le publier
un livre 1e - un livre commenté c'est à
dire
ouais enfin que ce site à cette
apparaître mon éventuellement le
verbatim commenté du spectacle commenté
par écrit commentée par ouais si j'en
remets ton le livre que tu as vu avec le
plus de notre boîte ballon retombe une
existence et c'est une lecture une
lecture est comment dire voyons c'est
quoi le mot que cherche et qui on va
voir non mais oui je pense ça marche
bien moi j'essaie je suis complètement
copier de mon humoristes préférés ou une
ligue qui a fait paraître tous ces shows
en version annotée tease à dire que et
il nous décrit à peu près tout comment
se passe le spectacle cepici ndjock qui
a vaincu paul vi à bruz sommet qui a
marché en débit à londres un temps ils
nous ont tous des affaires qui juge
qu'ils sont un peu pertinente de
mentionner c'est tout le pourquoi du
comment c'est djoko est arrivé moi j'ai
lu j'ai vu ce tour dit j'ai lu sous
eclipse ça me le fait encore plus
apprécié le ton humoristique mais c'est
un essayiste ou si le souci c'est
vraiment un cerveau qui au fait que mon
cerveau cc c'est l'humoriste qui fait
que j'ai compris quel humour ça peut
être autre chose que qu'est ce que je
pensais que c'était lui mots ça m'a
vraiment fait changer ma façon de faire
de l'humour csu complètement copier mais
plus j'étais une éponge astorc lille
mérite ainsi qu'aux règles parce que lui
dans son lit vidic ont le droit d'être
une éponge à d'autres humoristes qui
mentionne ses inspirations à lui qui ont
entièrement copiés facture j'ai juste
regardé une seule copie exacte où s
conduit ou est ce contexte qu'est ce
qu'on fait si la demande qui écoute ce
qui te connaissais pas qui a mis
quelques pièces comme s'il faut danser
sur un stage aussi vierges portant ce
n'est pas la plus petite
moi y'a plein de soins papier parce
qu'après ouais on s'ajustera star
puisque j'ai complètement délaissé ma
fan page puis moi on me suis serein
stamm et on sera dans la rue le soir
d'autres fois je suis sérieux c'est
vraiment ça n'aurait toutefois je marche
ça rit comme minuit je revenais chez
nous piller et je vois monsieur au loin
sur le trottoir près de medea ses
collègues on dit bonjour mademoiselle
fait pas ça on dit pas bonjour
mademoiselle ou fit seul soit on fait
pas ce que tu attends on fait attention
fait suivez moi si j'étais vous parlez à